hello everyone
in this video we'll talk about cell
culture
cell culture refers to removal of a cell
from an animal or
plant and subsequently culturing it in a
favorable
artificial growth situation for example
you can see here
a lung cell has been taken out of the
organ situation
and kept in a culture so the lung
epithelial cell can be cultured
and in the next example you can see the
meristem or a portion of the leaf
is cultured in an artificial media to
grow a
intact plant so for both plant
and for both animal cells they can be
cultured
in vitro or outside of the organ
and that is known as cell culture so
this video is
all about cell culture we would learn
about basic terminologies which are
super important
to understand cell culture first we
would learn about
primary cell culture so primary cell
culture starts with the dissociation of
cell from
a parental animal tissue it could be
also plant tissue
and enzymatic digestion or mechanical
digestion is performed
to get rid of the tissue organization
and kind of like free the cells from
these tissue-like settings
so repeated up and down with trypsin or
several enzymes such as acute
etc can get rid of these tissue-like
organization
ultimately it would become cell
suspensions
now these cell suspensions are plated
onto specific
media which would support the growth of
these cells and that becomes
our primary tissue culture that means
from the organ you isolate the cell and
plate it on a
culture setting and that gives you the
primary
cell culture now these primary cell
culture has different growth kinetics
first of all there would be a lag phase
where there would be no significant
growth
followed by a log phase exponential
growth phase where the cells would grow
in an exponential fashion and lastly
as the cells grow the media gets
limiting and also there is not enough
surface area for growth
so all of these factor leads to a
plateau phase
so whenever a cell culture or whenever a
cultured cell
reach these plateau phase you would see
this is termed as confluent cells
confluency is commonly used as a measure
of cell numbers and
i mean cell surface area versus the
surface area of the culture
dish just to get an idea that how much
crowded these cells are
if it is too much confluent then it
won't get enough amount of media or
necessary nutrients for its growth
so when they are super confluent then
you need to
subculture them and first time you
subculture
from these cell types then they would be
known as a cell line
so cell line is just
a subclone which is derived after the
first subculture
so from this culture you see these cells
are now confluent it's time to separate
them
into two different hubs and we term
it as subculture so after subculturing
it would be termed as a cell line
now cell line which is derived from a
primary culture
have limited life span and as they are
passage
many cells which are having highest
capacity of growth
they predominate the culture so this
results
in a high degree of genotypic and
phenotypic similarity or uniformity
in these cell culture or in this
cultured cell population
so let us quickly compare the properties
of primary cells
versus cell lines so obviously i would
say the primary cell has a very high
biological relevance compared to a cell
line
i'll tell you why in a moment but
if you talk about the life span both
could have sort of like
the primary cell could have like a
limited to finite life span where cell
lines are generally infinite
or unlimited now there are many other
points
where they differ but these primary cell
culture
recapitulates the tissue like
organization way more than the cell
lines i'll tell you why but before that
let's try to understand this process
in a lab setting in order to understand
cell culture we have to virtually
explore a cell culture lab
so here is a cell culture lab you can
see the essential components it should
be very
clean and it should be tidy so in this
cell culture lab
on the right hand corner you can see
there is a biosafety cabinet all the
actions would take place here before
looking at the bioseptic cabinet
let us look at other components so you
can see just left side of the biosfg
cabinet there are two hoods
there are two incubators which are
important for keeping the cells and
they would provide the proper
environment for the cell to grow
other than that there would be
centrifuges microscope cell counter
etc so there are certain norms that you
have to follow when you are
working on a cell culture lab such as
wearing a lab coat all the time a
covered lab coat obviously and if you
are culturing
something which is infectious or any
other
ah serious material then you should have
a
additional layer of protection you have
you should have your proper ppe kit
in order to culture the cells now guys
what you need to understand is
what is inside the hood these hoods are
generally what is depicted here is a
classical bsl 2 hood or biological
safety level 2 hood
however biological safety level 3 and
safety level 4 hoods are very different
looking
and other videos we'll talk about that
but not in this video
so you can see there are many
uh things which are associated with cell
culture should be placed in the hood
but it should be first sprayed with
alcohol
and then it should be kept inside the
hood such that it is contamination free
now while working in the hood it is
always permissible that you wear lab
coat
and having proper gloves and other
protective equipments
this would prevent contamination and
also save you for
from any kind of bio hazards so let's
try to understand
how we can prepare a hippocampal primary
cell culture
just to get an example so in order to
culture the hippocampal neurons we need
to isolate brain
from mouse generally in lab mouse are
available right so you can take mouse
embryo out
and take out the embryonic brain in a
ice cold pbs solution
now after dissecting these brain in an
ice cold solution you would
dissect out the hippocampus and collect
it in a particular tube containing
trypsin
acutase or pronase so all of these
enzymes
are able to dissociate these content
of this tissue so all the cell types
which are present in that tissue would
be dissociated now
so obviously you put it in the incubator
for some time such that the enzyme can
work and
after that you pipe it up and down
vigorously
such that it creates a cell suspension
now after that it is necessary to count
the cells to get an estimate how much
cell you need to plate in a culture
roughly about a million or 1.5 million
cells
are a good material to start with and it
also depends upon flux volume volume or
kind of a container where we are
culturing the cell
i just talked about a 10 centimeter
plate now after that you resuspend these
uh cells in the media the cell
suspension you you make a cell
suspension in the media
and then what you have to do you have to
centrifuge them and wash them
because the trip scene which is already
there in that
media would be harmful so you need to
get rid of these trypsin
so supernatant is discard whereas the
pellet of cells is retained
after the trypsin is gone then again the
cells are
washed with pbs and ultimately
resuspended
with the culture media now this culture
media
which we add we pipe it vigorously in
this step
to mix our cells to break the clump of
cells and make them a suspension and
finally
we plate them in a 10 centimeter plate
or whatever plate
that we have in supply and this is how
we establish
a primary culture now all this thing is
just
in a animated fashion right so let's
look at
this process in bit more details in a
realistic setup
so ultimately you would put it in an
incubator for their growth and monitor
them almost every day and change the
media every alternate day
and lastly you have to check it in the
microscope
right to check their growth in this case
you can see
these neurons are taking their shape and
forming connections in this culture
so let's look at the original process so
here you can see a mouse embryo
and then you can dissect out the brain
like this and from a from this brain you
know where the hippocampus is situated
so you can micro dissect this
hippocampus
and culture them and in a culture
setting in a very early stage you see
hardly they have new rights and
projections and connection in between
then
whereas at the late stage you can see
quite a lot of connection has been
formed inside them and if you track
their progression over days
you would appreciate how in the culture
setting they are growing and forming
connections with each other and making a
functional neural network so obviously
this is a mature neuronal network which
is depicted in this
image and curtsy of course google images
now
let us talk about two different type of
cell culture
paradigm one is known as adherent cell
culture another is suspension cell
culture
so adherent cell culture is basically
what the cells get adhered with the
plate material generally the plate need
to be coated with some kind of
extracellular matrix
proteins such as lamin fibronectin
sometimes such that these cells get a
substratum on which they can grow
whereas many cells don't need this
substrate of our growth
imagine a blood cell obviously in in the
in vivo setting they are floating here
and there so obviously
in a cultured setting they can also
float so obviously it's easy to handle a
suspension cell culture
than uh adherent cell culture and it's
easier to
sort of like subculture them and a lot
of difference has been noted
here now let me tell you why these
culture systems are not so good these
culture systems has some advantage but a
lot of disadvantage
imagine you have a circuit organization
in vivo in a certain fashion
so certain amount of glial cell is
connecting a certain
amount of neuron in a specific
stoichiometric ratio that ratio that
organization cellular connection these
might be totally jumbled up
when you are culturing because you are
first breaking the way of connection
formation
and then you are allowing it to be
forming spontaneously
so exactly the rules or the micro
environment
in which these connections form would be
very different
that means though culture settings can
allow the cells to be grown in vitro
but they have a lot of limitation as a
researcher it is really important to
understand the limitations
such that we can design our own
experiments right
so obviously we have certain advantages
such as like the primary cell cultures
they are more closer
towards the in vivo settings than
a cell line
because cell lines sometimes there are
chromosomal aberrations
there are growth related problems so
really we have to understand
what kind of issue we want to chase
in this cell in this cell culture
paradigm
based on that we would use our cell
lines either a primary one
or a cell line right
so i hope that was uh comprehensive
enough
but many of the people stopped using
this dissociation culture
method these days the primary culture
method instead of that they started
using
organotypic culture so it's impossible
to culture the brain
in total but if we slice the brain then
these thin slices can be cultured
because nutrient can reach inside
but whereas in an intact brain it is
very difficult for this nutrient to flow
deep inside the brain and that is why
there would be necrosis but in this
settings
a large surface area is in contact with
the culture media so all these neurons
would get some amount of
culture media to thrive and that is why
organotypic culture
is a very good culture system these days
and lot of researchers are using these
organotypic culture in a different video
we'll talk about organotypic culture
cell culture media etc
so stay tuned and watch my channel
if you like this video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe
and do follow me in patreon you can also
be my patreon just paying only four
dollars per month
and guys i'm also present in an academy
so you can access all of my courses in
an academy using my code ap 10 you would
get a 10
discount so hurry up and thanks for
listening thank you guys